Welcome to another episode of What's Up,
Prof? Hi, Martin. Hi, Walter. I'm
waiting every time now for you. How are
you? I'm fine, thank you.
All right, Martin, we're going to call
this one then and now. Yeah. Basically,
history repeats itself, right? Yes.
Bible says it will be like that. And
yeah, Solomon says there's nothing new
under the sun. Yeah.
So, we're going to have a look at
history unfolding itself and the final
events that will take place on Earth.
You see, one aspect that's very
important to realize that history will
repeat itself is if you realize that, if
you can and you put that into the study
that you do, you won't go off in putting
the attention to the wrong place.
Yes.
Uh backdrop has a modern city in the
center,
ancient cities in the past, conflicts,
biblical aspects,
and a repetition throughout history.
But, we're interested in final events
and where we are heading.
So, let's have a look at this. Yeah.
There's a book in the Bible where you
get the history that will be repeated.
Yes, and the history is very accurate.
And it is irrefutable.
Ah.
So, we're going to look at Daniel 11
and
verses 30 to 36
and verses 40 to 45.
So, Daniel 11:30 to 36 is is history.
Mhm.
But, history is to be repeated in
another form. So, that's still to come.
And that'll bring us to the end. Yeah.
So, that's basically where we're
heading.
Basically where we're heading. And it's
it's it's nice to see this because if
you take the history part of Daniel
11:30 to 36 and you apply
that similar events has to happen, then
you can't get sidetracked other places.
Correct.
So, let's have a look at Daniel 11.
For the ships of Kittim shall come
against him.
Therefore, he shall be grieved and
return and have indignation against the
holy covenant. So shall he do, he shall
even return and have intelligence with
them that forsake the holy covenant. So,
we're we're talking about the historic
aspect here. Mhm.
The ships of Kittim have been
subject of discussion in biblical
circles for long, long time.
What exactly does it mean?
Uh
is it literal? Of course, it can't be
literal in the sense.
Where do these ships of Kittim come
from? People associated it with Cyprus.
Mhm. So, it comes from the west,
basically. How does it apply to to
Israel? How does it apply to Jerusalem?
And is it is it something that will
happen from the west or how do you see
it? Well, even if we say it comes from
the west, what came from the west? The
Roman Empire.
Yes.
So, we'll leave it at that and
whether it is precisely that or not is
open to conjecture.
But, it fits the the prophetic profile.
Yeah.
Now, who's the he we are talking about?
Well, it is somebody who has great
indignation against the holy covenant.
Mhm.
So, in a sense, it is Satan, but of
course, it is his agent. Peace. And we
are here in the book of Daniel in
chapter 11. We've gone through the
battles between the king of the south
and the king of the north and we've
moved from the literal historic events,
history
Mhm. going to the spiritual battle
between the philosophies of the king of
the north and the king of the south. So,
basically, we're talking about the
papacy.
And he has a problem
in that he has to combat something,
these ships from Kit- Kittim.
Mhm. And he's struggling to rise to
ascendancy.
Mhm.
Is that right?
That sounds right. So, he has a covenant
against those who are arrayed against
the holy covenant. In other words,
they're opposed to God's word. Yeah.
And so shall he do, and he shall even
return and have intelligence with them
which forsake the holy covenant.
Now, that means he will have
discussions Mhm. with all who are
arrayed against the holy covenant. Now,
imagine that includes the Martin, that
includes the whole world.
That's it. So, alliance. Does it include
uh
the Jewish nation that rejected Jesus?
Yes.
And all the other nations, anybody who
rejects the covenant is welcome in that
circle.
For sure.
And arms shall stand on his part, Mhm.
and they shall pollute the sanctuary of
strength.
Martin, they're going to they're going
to fight against the sanctuary. Mhm.
Now, it can't be a literal sanctuary
anymore because that was destroyed in 70
AD already.
Yeah.
So, this is the rise of the papacy.
Yes. Now, what was holding it back?
Pagan Rome was holding it back. It
couldn't rule secularly
unless the Roman Empire
the pagan power fell.
Yes. And that happened in the time of
Constantine, right?
And then it was transferred to the
papacy. The Roman seat was empty.
The Roman pagan power had moved to
Constantinople.
It had taken on a Christian face,
although it was a mixture of paganism
and Christianity.
Yeah. Actually, just a revamped pagan.
Yes, and then there was the so-called
gift of Constantine
that empowered the pope to take the
political power as well.
So, pagan Rome gave him his seat, his
power, and great authority.
And behind the Roman power is the
dragon.
Yes.
All right.
So, arms shall stand on his part and
shall pollute the sanctuary
and shall take away the daily sacrifices
added.
Mhm.
And they shall place the abomination
that makes desolate. What happened
historically over here? Well, Rome
in its papal form couldn't gain the
ascendancy until pagan Rome fell.
Yeah. Yeah.
And was that achieved through arms? Yes.
Yes.
There were wars. There were three powers
that were opposed
Mhm. to the rise of the papacy, the
really the Ostrogoths and the Vandals,
and these had to be removed, and these
were removed through the power of Rome.
Military power that removed the three,
and then having uprooted these three
horns, here rises the papacy,
and it sets up the
abomination that makes desolate. Now,
Martin, could that be church and state
coming together? Definitely. And
inventing
dogmas and laws that are contrary to the
covenant of God. That's exactly what it
can be. So, it must be against God's
law.
Yes. And against God's rule.
And make it own its own rules. Yes. And
such as do wickedly against the covenant
shall he corrupt with flatteries.
So, he's not really on the side of God,
is he? No, because he's flattering and
it's actually wicked. Yes, and flattery
is is an attribute of the devil.
Mhm.
But, the people that do know their God
shall be strong and do exploits. In
other words, they will resist him. Mhm.
They will continue preaching the gospel,
and he will be furious.
Once again, there's a remnant.
And there's a fury against the remnant.
And he will try to destroy them.
Yeah.
And they that understand
amongst the people shall instruct many.
Now, great understanding have they that
love thy law.
Isn't that interesting? And Daniel said
that those that understand will lead
many to righteousness.
Yeah. Yeah.
Now, if you lead someone to
righteousness, whose righteousness are
you leading them to?
righteousness. Okay. So, there will be
an opposition
against those that preach
the truth as it is in Jesus. Yes, for
sure.
Yet they shall fall by the sword and by
flame, by captivity and by spoil many
days. That's a rather sad statement.
Now, the many days obviously is a
reference to the 1,260
years of papal supremacy, right?
Yes.
Which happened from which years? 538 to
1798.
Okay.
So, those that understand will fall by
the sword. Now, who were they?
That was the true church. Yes. In the
beginning it was the church in the east.
Mhm.
And their
doctrines and their truth was carried
into the west by the Waldensians. But
just before you go there, where did this
truth come from? Okay, that was the
church then, but it came from the
disciples, correct?
from the disciples and their seat was in
the east. It was in Syria. It was in
Antioch.
Mhm.
And from there the truth spread. Now,
this power is in the west.
Mhm.
And then the Waldensians and the
Albigensians and all of those and to a
measure the Celtic church, the early
Celtic church, they were Sabbath keepers
and they carried the gospel of
salvation.
And they relied upon the Bible and the
Bible alone.
Yeah. So, they were for the covenant.
Right? They were for the for the good
book. The the then the backdrop we have
the Bible.
And
this is what they stood for and they
were ruthlessly hounded
Mhm.
by numerous methodologies.
You had the crusades.
Yeah. And you had
the activities surrounding the
Waldensians, the wars in the Piedmont
Valley. It was a horrendous time and and
people died in their thousands, in their
hundreds of thousands.
And it's
if we can just for a moment think of it.
We've if you put 10 years or even 50
years thinking of it's quite a some
time. Yes.
Now, for this to be a 1,260
years. That's a long, long time. There's
there's actually
how quickly can you get rid of something
through two generations? If somebody was
doing this, you can get
and there's not a story being told onto
the generations is lost. So, how good
was God to keep this remnant going that
whole time? Could never be destroyed.
And eventually the reformation was
raised up
and the reformation put the covenant and
the Bible back into the center.
But the Bible says, "I did not find your
work complete." Oh.
So, somebody had to arise sooner or
later to complete the work.
Yes, to have it complete. Okay, that's
Okay.
So, here we have the situation. They
instructed many, but they fell by the
sword. They were
hounded, made war against and suffered
greatly.
Now, when they shall fall,
they shall be holpen with a little help.
But many shall cleave to them with
flatteries.
So, the Christian church was the true
Christian church that clung to the
covenant, they were hounded.
And then they were holpen with a little
help.
So, what helped them? Well, the earth
opened up
and swallowed up the water, which is the
nations, the multitudes that warred
against them in Europe. And they escaped
and they fled to places of haven like
the United States of America, for
example. Some came to Southern Africa.
Some went to new areas in the world. And
they were holpen a little bit.
But many shall cleave to them with
flatteries. So, even though they were
holpen, all is not well. Was there mixed
multitude?
Always a mixed multitude, Martin.
And some of them of understanding shall
fall
to try them and to purge and to make
them white even to the time of the end.
Because it is yet for a time appointed.
So, this is historic.
Mhm.
The time of the end begins in after
1798.
Yes, when the 1,260
years end.
When those 1,260
come to an end. Right.
So, many will be tried individually. You
have to make a choice.
And the king
shall do according to his will. So, the
ruling power behind this persecuting
empire
Mhm.
which stands for the papacy.
And he shall exalt himself and magnify
himself above every god and shall speak
marvelous things against the God of gods
and shall prosper
till the indignation be accomplished.
For that that is determined shall be
done.
So, Paul already spoke about this power
in Thessalonians where he said he will
sit in the temple.
And the reformers all recognized that
the temple is the church because the
Bible says, "Ye are the temple of the
living God." So, this power will present
itself
in the form of a Christian power sitting
in God's church pretending to be God,
changing God's laws, changing his
ordinances, warring against the
covenant.
And eventually he will be destroyed. And
this is all history. Yes, it's all past.
It is then. And there's no denying that
it happened.
Yes. And we have hindsight. We can look
at it.
We can ignore it, join the ecumenical
movement
Mhm.
and go back to this flattery
Yes.
and nonsense and forsake the holy
covenant for the sake of peace.
Or we could choose to stand by the holy
covenant. Which will bring fury up on
you. Which will bring major trouble.
So, this is history.
If you stood for the covenant,
you were a target.
Well, the earth holpen for a little
while.
But uh
there was so much flattery going on
that the holpenness sort of disappeared
by now.
Am I right?
That's true.
All right. Now, Martin, if he hates the
holy covenant
and he is fraternizing with flattery,
with all those that have forsaken the
holy covenant. In other words, they do
not believe
in salvation
Mhm.
according to the biblical principles and
they reject the Messiah, which is most
of the religious systems in the world,
including the papacy. Then we have to
have some evidence that what he is
talking about and what he is saying is
not biblical.
Yeah.
So, we've done this many times, but
let's just sum it up again briefly.
Why do they turn their back upon the
holy covenant? So, what is the Catholic
versus the biblical salvation? There
must be a difference.
And the reason why we also sometimes
bring up something like this again
is
this is going to happen again. Yes. In
fact, it is happening again.
We learn through history, we show the
history and then we have to learn what's
coming and what is. Okay. So, Martin, if
he turns his back on the holy covenant,
can you have a concord with him? No.
Not at all. Has light and darkness got
anything in common? Nothing. No.
So, let's just briefly answer this again
and ask ourselves,
what is the difference between the
Catholic and biblical salvation? How has
Catholicism, not Catholics, because they
don't know,
how has the system turned its back on
the holy covenant
and persecuted those that stuck to it?
Yeah.
So, how does the Catholic view of
salvation differ from the biblical view
and why does it differ? That's an
important question, isn't it? For sure.
It's the crux of the matter.
It's because otherwise
and a lot of people will ask,
"Why is it so important that we know?"
Yes. And he's such a nice man. And he
wears such a nice white robe. Mhm.
Yes, but underneath he wears black
clothes if you look carefully.
So, let's look at the why first.
The Catholic view differs from that of
the Bible because it is dictated by
tradition and not by scripture.
And every council has emphasized that
the Council of Trent in particular.
Many of the fathers of the church were
Gnostics, such as Origen and Eusebius.
And once their views became infallible
dogmas, they could by definition not be
changed because they were infallible.
Infallible.
And these dogmas are based on Greek
philosophy and not the Bible.
That's why when you get to Revelation
13,
he has the body of a leopard.
Yeah. He That's his structure. It's
Greek philosophy. It's not biblical.
It's turning the back against the holy
covenant.
All right. So, how do they differ?
Number one, they differ in terms of the
atonement.
Yes. Jesus dying for your sins.
Yes.
Catholic theology denies the atonement
just as verily as the other major
religions, such as Islam,
do.
Judaism or Judaism or any form of
paganism.
They claim that you are saved by his,
Jesus's, good works and not by his
substitutionary death. You're not saved
by the blood of the lamb.
In the same way, the good works of the
saints and Mary can do the same.
Taken to its logical conclusion, then
the saints and Mary could do it too by
offering to God a gift that is greater
than that which is taken away by the sin
of other individuals. An exchange, as it
were, of something good for something
bad. Okay.
It's all Yeah. That's Catholic theology.
And if you take it to its natural
conclusion, they say that the good deeds
of Mary are pristine in the eyes of God.
So, basically, you could sidetrack Jesus
because maybe that's enough. And may
a lot of them do. Yes. They pray to to
Mary. Yes.
Secondly, the Catholic theology denies
that Jesus paid the price for sin.
This means that each sinner must pay his
own price. Oh, yeah. Of course.
Logical.
Purgatory.
Either by going to hell Mhm. if his or
her sin is not forgiven, or if it is
forgiven by the power invested in the
priest,
then he or she must still pay the price
before going to heaven.
And for this, they invented purgatory.
Which is a place where you pay off the
price of sin. Of necessity, this brings
with us another can of worms, namely the
doctrine of immortality.
Because you're going to live forever.
Either in hell
or in heaven after having been purged in
purgatory.
So, sinners live forever then as well.
Yes. Where's the Where's the
righteousness of Christ imputed and
imparted here? It is nonexistent. So,
actually, not sinners live forever, but
sin as well, if this is true. It will be
eternal. If you read your Bible and you
read the second statement that you've
just read,
I cannot understand how you cannot see
that it doesn't gel with the Bible at
all.
It's the complete opposite. If you're
not saved by the blood of the lamb,
you're not saved.
So, number three, Catholic theology
teaches that man can become righteous by
his good works
rather than the biblical doctrine of man
receiving the imputed righteousness of
Christ by faith in him.
Salvation in Catholicism is thus
man-centered
and the biblical salvation is
Christ-centered.
Relief from the punishment of sin comes
via the treasury of merit and
indulgences.
So, the papacy has at its disposal this
treasury of all the good works and deeds
of everybody
that was good, which includes the works
of Jesus, but also Mary and the saints.
And these works are so pristine,
especially Mary's,
that there is so much merit that you can
hand out.
Yeah. And
the Pope can decide to have a year a
jubilee year Yes.
And then he can hand out this merit as
he pleases, but why and then close it
again. Yes, and then he can relieve you
from the punishment of sin in purgatory.
They can sell you an indulgence or give
you an indulgence for a good deed.
Because we need some merit
to keep it going, all right?
And then, uh,
you can be relieved of the punishment.
Now, Martin, if you are relieved of the
punishment, do you then actually pay for
it? No. No, it doesn't even make any
sense. It's such a gobbledygook
situation. And it's
sad that people are caught up in this.
Right.
I mean
Sorry, but how how big is this church?
Massive.
1.something billion people. Yes. And And
they believe this. Now,
I myself was a Catholic, as you know.
So, this is this is so unbiblical, it's
it's baffling.
Now, what's interesting,
here you are
and
you are in this system, and and where
does it come from?
How did it evolve? Why do you have to
have indulgences? Why do you have to
have a purgatory? Because you have to
pay for your own sins.
So, in a sense, they say the good works
of Mary or Jesus or the saints
pay for those sins in a sense, but it is
a bloodless offer.
There is no blood involved, and without
the shedding of blood, there's no
forgiveness of sins, right?
So, where does this question of
purgatory come from? Well, let's go to
catholics365,
and there's the webpage, and they say,
as we saw in our first installment,
limbo
was never a true doctrine of the Roman
Church. Now, limbo was another state
that the Roman Catholic Church invented
because they didn't know exactly what to
do with babies that died without being
baptized.
So, they, according to their thinking,
they hadn't sinned yet, so they can't go
to hell.
They hadn't committed a sin, so they
can't go to purgatory.
So, they put them in limbo.
So, you were neither in heaven nor in
hell, you were somewhere floating
between. You were excluded from heaven
because you weren't baptized. Oh. So, I
So, there's nothing for you.
thief on the cross also had to end up in
limbo, actually.
Because he also wasn't baptized, but
let's leave that. So, Martin, they
invented limbo, but it was never a
really
full-blooded Catholic doctrine.
And fortunately,
Pope Benedict Ah.
the precursor of Pope Francis
got rid of limbo. Recently. Yes. I don't
know what happened to all those babies
that were in limbo. Maybe they shot
straight up into heaven due to the
kindness of Pope Benedict.
But nevertheless,
limbo often became
entangled
with the doctrine of purgatory.
Now, this is what they say. Purgatory
has an origin in Greek mythology and
philosophy.
As the ancient Greeks believed in a type
of limbo and purgatory. Now, how did it
become Catholic doctrine? Mhm.
It was Clement of Alexandria
in 150 to 215 AD, renowned Catholic
theologian and philosopher, who argued
that the dead could be cleansed of sin
by a purifying fire.
However, Pope Gregory the Great, whose
reign was 590 to 604,
taught in the history of the Christian
doctrines that the cleansing fire was a
matter of unquestioned belief.
Now, 590 to 604, that is after the
papacy ascended to the papal chair.
So, immediately, they introduced a Greek
philosophy
that negates the plan of salvation.
And that Greek philosophy is
pagan.
Does it turn your weapons against the
holy covenant?
Yes, for sure. That falls right into
history in place. And Pope Gregory the
Great has been called the inventor of
purgatory. So, right from the beginning,
they undermined the plan of salvation
and sought those by flattery who would
go along with them. That's everybody
else. And that is why it's important to
still know exactly what this church
teaches today. Yes. Have they changed?
No. Pope Francis just handed out a major
uh, indulgence. Yes.
So, let's go to verse 14.
And at the time of the end,
that is 1798, because that's when the
1,260-year
prophecy comes to an end. 538 to 1798 is
1,260 years. So, that was the history
portion. Yes.
And from now, it comes to the now and
From the time of the end, from then
onwards.
And at the time of the end, shall the
king of the south push at him.
Give him a shove.
Does that mean get rid of him? No, not
at all. No, just
Just irritate him a bit. Give him a
whack.
And of course, we're dealing with this
concept of this these two powers, the
Seleucid kingdom and the Ptolemy kingdom
that were constantly at loggerheads with
each other. And now we are using this in
a spiritual form.
Yes, so that was the literal king of the
north and king of the south.
Yes. Now, we'll get to that portion, but
this is definitely not the physical No.
geographical place.
No, because we are now past the Greek
empire. We are now in Roman history.
And we're in papal history. So, it
cannot be the literal king of the north.
It must be what he stood for. And the
king of the south said, "I do not know
God. Why should I obey him?
I don't want God in the schools. I don't
want the 10 Commandments as my norm."
And he got rid of it. Now, this happened
during the French Revolution where
reason
was enthroned
over and above the word of God. And this
became the philosophy of the world.
Yes.
And church and state were separated.
That what happened after 1798.
After 1798.
And liberty, liberty from what? From the
oppression of scripture because
scripture was banned became the
watchword. And France gave the Statue of
Liberty, which is really the Statue of
Mitra,
as a gift
to the United States of America. So,
that's sun worship. Do what thou wilt is
the whole of the law. We don't want any
mingling of church and state. So, the
papacy got a push. Did France give that
for a certain reason?
Well, it was this new state of liberty.
And the constitution that was
introduced over there, as we've
discussed, had Jesuit footprints in it.
Because I was just thinking, why would a
secular, they've just recently went
through their renaissance and all gotten
rid of the of the Bible, why would they
then they be so happy to give a
a statue to a Christian country? Because
it was this power that had arisen, this
philosophy out of the bottomless pit.
Wow.
It was the undercover agency of Roman
Catholicism
with its spearhead army, the Jesuits.
So, actually, they were still in charge,
but just undercover. It seemed to have a
mortal wound. Ellen White
doesn't say it had a mortal wound. And
he got a shove.
Now, A shove means just get out of the
way for a while until we create so much
turmoil in the world that we'll welcome
you back with 10,000 kisses. We can see
that We see that happening, right?
Okay.
And eventually, history is summed up
here that the king of the north shall
come against him, against this
philosophy of secularism,
with chariots, in other words, military
activity,
horsemen, that's military, ships, that's
the economy.
And he shall enter into the countries,
plural, and shall overflow and pass
over. He'll
swamp the world with his philosophy.
He shall enter also into the glorious
land.
And many countries shall be overthrown,
but these shall escape out of his hand,
even Edom
and Moab and the chief of the children
of Ammon.
Now, the the Moabites, the
Ammonites, they were all associated with
Abraham. Yeah, they were family they
were actually family of Israel. Yes,
they arose out of separation and
apostasy.
But they were still affiliated. Let's
call them the sister churches.
And
some of them will escape.
Yeah. So, So, in other words, they are
in a system, trapped in a system which
the Bible calls Babylon.
But God acknowledges that some of his
wayward children are in Babylon, and he
will call them out. So, they will escape
his grasp, which is good news.
Very good. But he's going to attack even
the glorious land. That tells you that
it will not be smooth sailing. No, it
won't be smooth sailing. Some want to
apply the glorious land to the United
States of America,
but let's say I would prefer to think of
it as an attack against the remnant.
Yes. I agree with you. And that has
brothers and sisters in the other
systems, the Edom and Moab systems.
Ah.
All right, then he'll stretch forth his
hand also upon the countries,
and the land of Egypt shall not escape.
So, in other words, he's going to
overrun the system of secularism.
Yeah, that king of the south that pushed
Mhm.
It's interesting that the head of the
Heritage Foundation recently said Mhm.
uh that this revolution
against the secularism can be a
bloodless one if the left allows it.
Yeah. And now you've got um Trump that
distanced himself from the Project 2025.
Oh, but that's a political move, Martin.
You know why? Mhm.
Because the the left has used this
information to hammer him politically,
and it's it could hurt him.
So, distance yourself a little bit, say
that you don't go along, you have your
own view.
Yeah, yeah. But if you look at the
administration and how they are
involved,
you know, You see, when I read
I for sure if I when I read that article
about it,
his wording
is maybe a little bit well thought out.
Yes, and he didn't say he condemns it
all. He says some of it.
portions of it. And he didn't mention
which ones. No, he didn't.
But he shall have power over the
treasures of gold and silver. So, who
controls the economy? The papacy.
Papacy.
And over all the precious things of
Egypt,
he controls even what they are using.
All the
multi-billionaire money, he's in control
of it. Weren't they all
at his feet, all these businessmen? For
sure. And this has been coming the whole
time through history.
And the Libyans and the Ethiopians shall
be at his steps. Where he goes, they
will follow.
Wonder after the beast.
All right, so he's even talking about
those regions which today are largely
run by Islamic
uh entities. Ethiopians
originally
even kept the Sabbath. Yes.
Uh
The Queen of Sheba wasn't she from
Ethiopia?
Yes.
But tidings out of the east and out of
the north shall trouble him. Therefore,
he shall go forth with great fury to
destroy and utterly to make away many.
All right. Now, Martin, he is the king
of the north.
Well, why should the north trouble him?
And why should the east trouble him?
Is this a military power that's coming
out of the north and out of the east as
many people would have it?
What is it that troubles him out of the
north? Where's the throne of God? In the
north.
And Christ, when he returns, where does
he come from?
From the east.
from the east.
So, there's a message that bugs him.
Yes. And the message is worship God and
give glory to him and not to this
apostate power.
Exactly.
That's an attack on from the north.
That's it.
And
Christ is going to come, and judgment
will take place. That's a message out of
the east.
Because I saw the glory come from the
east.
So, this is agitating him because
he's got
the whole world wondering after him, but
there's this irritating message He can't
stand it. He can't stand the message of
the remnant, so he will go out to
destroy utterly and to take them away.
And he shall plant the tabernacle of his
palace between the seas, that's the
nations,
in the glorious holy mountain.
Yet he shall come to his end, and none
shall help him. He'll even try to
infiltrate. Yeah. First, he
he got rid of the heads and tortured.
And then
inside.
So, what he did in the past when he
attacked the Waldenses and when he
destroyed the Albigenses and when he
destroyed
the Sabbath-keeping nations of the
world,
then
uh Martin,
he will do the same at the time of the
end. So, what was then
will be now with a difference.
Mhm. With a difference, namely that this
is the last game, and Christ will
intervene as he did against Pharaoh.
This is the end game. This is the end
game. And just for people that probably
know,
there's that Hollywood movie, The
Avengers. They also had a end game
where the
the good and evil fight.
But unfortunately,
God is the only one
that will be the victor in the end of
this one. Absolutely.
All right, so we have no time to lose.
Troubles times are before us. The world
is stirred with the spirit of war.
Soon the scenes of trouble spoken of in
the prophecies will take place.
The prophecy in the 11th of Daniel has
nearly reached its complete fulfillment.
Do you go along with that? 100%. But if
it says it's nearly reached its complete
fulfillment,
it means it hasn't been fulfilled yet.
So
we can't put
we can't put some of those things in
history.
That is not
that does not fit there.
Much of the history that has taken place
in fulfillment of this prophecy will be
repeated.
In the 30th verse, a power is spoken of
that shall be grieved and return and
have indignation against the holy
covenant. So shall he do, he shall even
return and have intelligence with them
that forsake the holy covenant.
Scenes similar to those described in
these words will take place.
So he's going to have liaisons with all
that turn their backs on what the Bible
teaches. And if we read this portion,
can we then put this power to anybody
else than the papacy?
There's none that qualifies other than
them. This clearly says that the verses
that we've just read and what happened
in the verse 30 to 36,
that power will reappear. Now if you
acknowledge a power that has negated the
plan of salvation
as the primacy in the Christian world,
have you then turned your back upon the
holy covenant? Yes. That's crucifying
Christ afresh, right?
So very similar scenes will take place.
We see the evidence that Satan is fast
obtaining the control of human minds who
have not the fear of God before them.
Let all read and understand the
prophecies of this book for we are now
entering upon the time of trouble spoken
of.
Now Martin, this was written a a long
time ago.
But as soon as these prophecies are
being fulfilled before your eyes, then
we are entering into the time spoken of.
So it had to happen after 1798. It had
to.
And it has been growing and culminating
to this point.
So let's try and summarize this. Daniel
11:30 to 36,
that's historic.
That's the then.
Daniel 11:40 to 45, that's the now.
So the verses 30 to 36, they're history.
And then similar scenes will take place
in verses 40 to 45. They were helping
the little
and the last remnant must be helping a
lot.
All right? They
must be saved from this army that is
approaching where they can go nowhere
except that the Red Sea opens before
them.
Where the saving can come from? It
cannot be earthly, can it? Cannot
because they're all arrayed against the
remnant. So it has to be an intervention
from
God himself. The throne of the north
brings retribution from the east.
And the papacy hates that message. So
verse 30, papal Rome forms political
alliance with the kings of the earth.
This happened from AD 508, 533 and
finally 538.
When he ascended the papal chair. 508
was the year when Clovis, the king of
France, gave his power unto him
to help him to ascend to the throne.
Verse 31, military power on the papacy's
side.
It takes away the daily, paganism is
removed by papal Rome in 508
and brings it to fruition in the year
538 when the three powers that opposed
it
are removed with the Ostrogoths being
the last ones.
And then he sets up the abomination of
desolation which is the church and state
with its own rules contrary to God's
rule including a change of the Sabbath.
Wow,
all right?
Verse 33, persecution of the saints many
days, that's the 1260
year prophecy.
Verse 35, persecution continues until
the time of the end, 1798, which is also
the time of the deadly wound.
That's when the secular power was taken
away from the papacy by Napoleon's army.
It's actually like you mentioned a
supposedly mortal wound. Yes, it's a
supposed mortal wound.
The papacy went into exile
but it didn't cease.
So how will history be repeated?
Military force will support the king of
the north.
He'll have the armies on his side.
Church and state in union will be
formed. That's the abomination of
desolation with their
flagship. Yes. The flagship in
the mark of the beast. The mark of the
beast which says
that I am the one that sanctifies you.
Because the pope can release you from
purgatory.
I'm the one that releases you from the
penalty of sin. I'm the one, not Christ.
That's that's really a tremendous
blasphemy.
Can you imagine how God feels about
that? Man.
Yes, he's paid the price and here's this
usurper
claiming that power and prerogative for
himself.
I think he's heartbroken.
Persecution of the saints follows. It
will happen again.
And the king of the north and papal Rome
will eventually come to their final end.
They will be destroyed.
All right, let's have a look at the then
now in a little bit more detail. God's
people of the glorious land of ancient
Israel were caught in the crossfire of
the king of the north and the king of
the south.
We also caught caught in the crossfire.
And sometimes we choose sides.
And we shouldn't.
We should walk behind Jesus and get
behind him. Yes, don't go to the left or
to the right politically either
or religiously.
All right, to come at the end of time,
God's people in the glorious land are
also to be caught in a philosophical
crossfire between the apostate
Christianity and atheism.
And we can see that. Oh, it's happening.
Especially in the in the political
sphere now.
Yes.
What happened in France?
That have a vote, the right
took a landslide.
There were riots and burning and
everything and then what happened in the
second vote? Second vote the left took
it again.
All right, so the left is still there
but the Bible tells us that the left is
going to be run overrun by the
philosophy of the north. So it doesn't
really matter whether it's the left
ruling or the right.
Daniel 11:16, literal Judea is the
location of God's people and the
glorious land is the territory of God's
people after 1798. This is the territory
of the remnant church prior to the
shaking and the Sunday law.
And what's that territory? Everywhere.
Yes. And that will be the remnant
church. Yes. It must be a universal
church.
Because this is a universal conflict.
Martin, you know that there are only two
truly universal churches in the world.
And
the one is the papacy. Oh wow. See? And
the other one is the Seventh Day
Adventist Church.
That's just a fact.
And
I don't think it's coincidence.
I don't think so either.
And the papacy clearly says
that compromise is impossible. Either
you're a Protestant and a Seventh Day
Adventist or you're with him. That's it.
They say it quite bluntly.
So after AD 34, the Jewish nation is no
longer God's chosen people. Therefore
cannot be literal Judea anymore.
So what we have now as a nation is a
Masonic construct. Yes. It's definitely
not set up by God.
It's a Masonic construct. It's a
distraction. It's a distraction and what
they can do as individuals is become
part of the true Israel of God.
Just say that again.
So what they can do to be
on God's side
is to accept the plan of salvation, the
covenant,
which they practiced in their in their
typology with the sacrificial system.
Now they just have to apply it to the
Messiah.
And they become part of the Israel of
God. Exactly. So they can still be part
of the Israel of God.
Sure they can, but as a nation, no.
And then the king of the north enters
through the abomination of desolation,
which is church and state enforcing the
national Sunday law. And many shall be
overthrown, but some of the remnant will
give the loud cry.
Yeah.
Is that a summary?
That's what's supposed to be on the
horizon. So this is the parallel between
the then and the now.
Yeah.
Then they were hoping a little when they
were in hard places.
Now they have to be hoping a lot. Yeah.
All right, unfortunately many shall be
overthrown. Yes, these overthrown is now
part of this remnant. Yes.
As the storm approaches, a large class
who have professed faith in the third
angel's message,
but have not been sanctified through
obedience to the truth,
abandon their position and join the
ranks of the opposition. How important
is it that we accept the Laodicean
message?
Salvation.
Okay.
By uniting with the world
and partaking of its spirit, they've
come to view matters in nearly the same
light.
And when the test is brought, they are
prepared to choose the easy popular
side.
Men of talent and pleasing address who
once rejoiced in the truth employ their
powers to deceive and mislead souls.
They become the most bitter enemies of
their former brethren when Sabbath
keepers are brought before the courts to
answer for their faith.
These apostates are the most efficient
agents of Satan
to misrepresent and accuse them. And by
false reports and insinuations
to stir up the rulers against them.
And
we can see that this will definitely be
the case.
It's already happening. Can you
have you recently seen a lot of
ex
Seventh-day Adventist making videos
against the Adventist Church?
Yes, and I've received them from many
people who want us to say
why these people are not correct.
And you know, they always have the same
gripe. Obviously the spirit of prophecy
is one of their main gripes
because they refuse to accept
the message that would change their
hearts.
Yeah.
And they take the easy way.
And also those that follow strange
doctrines that make Jesus less than he
is. That's it. Martin, if you touch the
divinity of Christ,
you have attacked the covenant.
I agree with you 100%.
If he is not the I am,
then you've got a big problem. Take off
your shoes. You're standing on holy
ground.
If you if you want to mess
with the divinity of Christ,
then you have destroyed the plan of
salvation.
Amen.
All right, let's move to Daniel
41 to 45.
So let's look at the literal. He's
talking about Edom, Moab, and Ammon. Do
they still exist as nations? No, so
obviously we're talking
uh figuratively, right?
They were associated with Abraham.
Mhm. They were from the lineage of
Abraham even if they were
uh
a little bit apostate.
But if you go to spiritual antitype,
God's people in apostate churches that
respond to the loud cry message and that
come out of Babylon.
They would be represented by Edom, Moab,
and Ammon. What did the Moabitess Ruth
say?
Your God will be my God and your people
my people.
Aha. Okay, Martin. So they will respond.
Yeah. They will respond.
Verse 42, Egypt shall not escape. So the
king of the south, secularism, succumbs
to the king of the north.
Whether by choice or by force, it
doesn't matter. He's going to succumb.
It doesn't matter, for sure. It might be
a bloodless one as the Heritage
Foundation Bosch said.
Yeah.
Verse 43, power over gold and silver.
There he controls the economy. How's he
going to use it? No man can buy or sell.
The merchants of the earth are waxed
rich. Yeah. Revelation 18:3.
Here's the parallel. The parallel. And
this is already that we've shown for
years how this is actually what's behind
the scenes.
Okay, historically, how did he use it?
If you went against Bible doctrine, you
lost your land. Yeah. You were thrown
off your off your ground. You owned
nothing.
You were subscribed.
Done.
Was that a
political move?
Yes, for sure. Was it a religious move?
Yes.
Was it an economic move? Yes. So did he
apply sanctions before? Yes. You can
read it
in history
how he applied buying and selling as a
weapon against God's people in the
Middle Ages.
He's just going to perfect it Yeah. in
the last days. And these tools are so
much more effective now. So what was
then
will be now.
All right, verse 43b, the Libyans and
the Ethiopians.
Islam will also fall in line with the
kings of the north. Don't we already
have an Abrahamic concord?
Yes. Right? Between the Jews, Islam, and
Aren't they brothers? Yeah. Now, Martin,
do they both turn their weapons against
the holy covenant and say that Jesus is
not the mediator of the covenant and the
atonement never happened?
That's exactly.
So the king of the north seemingly has
control over the whole world.
Through his agents, he actually does.
Yes.
Verse 44, tidings out of the east and
the north
will disturb him.
So there comes a sealing message of the
loud cry by God's people that proclaims
that Babylon, the king of the north, is
fallen.
Okay? So this claim is not
he's actually still there.
But it the claim is that he's fallen
because God is going Jesus is going to
be the victor. All right, if we had to
unpack this a little bit, then we could
say
that the king of the north has always
been fallen from 508 onwards, 538 in
particular, because then he already
issued decrees
that set up the union of church and
state and got rid of the holy covenant.
That's it. So he was fallen because he
has turned his back completely on the
script.
So which portion of of Babylon, which
consists of three portions, the dragon,
the beast, and the false prophet, which
portion of it is fallen here at the end?
The false prophet. The false prophet.
Cuz he always claimed to be Christian.
He always believed in the atonement, but
he's chosen another boss.
Yeah.
He's signed the Charter Oecumenica,
which makes the Pope primate. Oh.
And that is all the like the apostate
churches that fall under
in this And he's signed the joint
declaration on justification,
which makes justification by works. Mhm.
So he goes forth to destroy them with a
death decree. So this this is the final
stage of the Sunday law. And why does to
be a Sunday law? We've discussed that in
our talk on the Sabbath.
Yes.
So if we go to verse 45, where it talks
about the
mountain,
and we look at the antitype or the end,
final union of church and state,
the final abomination of desolation,
church and state enforcing the papal
mark of the beast, Sunday law.
And eventually that leads to a death
decree. Yeah.
Just as in Joel 2:32, Jerusalem and
Mount Zion are synonymous with God's
remnant people who survived the shaking
and death decree.
The 144,000
are besieged by the masses of people
and the papacy led by the papacy, we
could say, right? Exactly. So once
again, just to emphasize, we cannot take
away
the
the crux that this will be done by the
papacy.
They are the spearhead. Yeah. They are
the spearhead, but somebody is doing it
on their behalf, the second beast of
Revelation, namely fallen Protestantism.
So Martin, when it comes to these
issues, we can say that wonderful events
are soon to open before the world. This
is a quote from the Review and Herald.
The end of all things is at hand. The
time of trouble is about to come upon
the people of God.
Then it is that the decree will go forth
forbidding those who keep the Sabbath of
the Lord to buy and sell
and threatening them with punishment and
even death if they do not observe the
first day of the week as the Sabbath.
So
somewhere in this timeline
Mhm.
probation will close. Yeah. But while
this is happening,
a loud cry will go out and people will
be invited to take their stand.
At that time shall Michael stand up.
Probation closes. Yes.
The judgement shall sit.
And here he stands up. So he's no longer
sitting.
The investigative judgement is passed.
And probation is closed. And that is
that portion where he puts off his
mediator attire and puts on his kingly
attire.
Correct.
So there's no more mediator for
humanity. God's people are sealed.
Mhm.
And
probation is closed.
And sealed means? So settled in the
truth that you cannot be moved.
Yeah.
Protected by the holy angels. Cuz God
will never leave you nor forsake you.
And the great prince would stand us for
the children of thy people and there
shall be a time of trouble
such as never was since there was a
nation. So when probation closes, you
have the great time of trouble. And then
the plagues will fall.
Yes, the plagues will fall. And this
will infuriate the nations even more.
Mhm.
And this will lead them to want to
implement the death decree.
And at that time thy people shall be
delivered, everyone that shall be found
written in the book. So that's when the
second coming of Christ takes place.
Yes. So
there will be a time of trouble
a Jacob's trouble that you have to
wrestle with God and
Cuz everything is against you.
Everything.
So and that's the portion where
And just maybe I can put it out there
again.
You should get yourself right before
that time. Yes. You should do all your
repentance. Get rid
repent before that time. No time to then
matter and moan at the banks of the Red
Sea.
You have to trust that God will open the
way. Amen.
So Daniel 12:1 at that time, at the time
that the king of the north besieges the
remnant which leads to the death decree,
Michael stands up and we have the close
of probation.
Yeah.
Let's look at the then time.
When probation closed for the Jewish
nation in AD 34, Stephen saw Jesus
standing at the right hand of God.
That was sort of a depiction of him
standing at the end. Yeah. The same will
happen. What happened for Jerusalem will
happen for the world.
And Jesus will be standing.
At the beginning of the judgement in
1844, the court was seated and the books
were opened.
So when probation closes at the end of
the world, Michael, Jesus, stands up.
Daniel 12:1.
Probation is closed.
Judgement has done its work.
Yeah. So And you're either on one side
or the other side. You have and you have
to make your choice before that time.
You have to make it before then.
And then you have the time of trouble
such as never was. And there shall be a
time of trouble such as never was. And
at that time thy people shall be
delivered. It's a promise.
So what happened then?
You have the tribulation of Matthew 24.
It is the 1,260
years.
And that is this great period that
lasted throughout the entire Middle
Ages.
And to come, the time of trouble is the
greatest in intensity and during this
time of trouble the seven last plagues
will fall.
Mhm.
And then God's people will be delivered.
So when they lift up that sword to
implement Yes, the death the death
decree, God intervenes.
Yeah.
Just like Pharaoh came with his army to
bring the sword
a death decree went out and they all
died. Amen.
So the deliverance of God's people
happens at the second coming of Jesus
during the seventh plague.
And that Martin is a summary
of events to come.
And I believe and I think you believe
that we are on the brink.
I think so, too.
I
especially with the
happening things happening all over. No
matter whether the left is is there or
the right is there, prophecy will be
fulfilled. Thank you. Amen. Let's pray.
Heavenly Father,
we thank you
that we have prophetic insights
through your holy word
which are to sustain us in the times
that are ahead so that when these things
happen, we will not be discouraged but
cling to the promises
which in you are yea and amen. In Jesus'
name,
amen.